[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIAN LIM: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the first ever
games track at Google I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't know if you
guys have noticed,
but Google I/O is kind
of a big deal to Google.
And so having our first ever
games-dedicated track is huge.
This is the first of many talks
for game developers this week.
So make sure to look for
the deep technical sessions,
sign up for a game
review, and check out
the demos in The Garage.
So I'm Tian, and I run products
and UX for Google Play.
Like many of you,
probably got your start
in computer science
because of games.
For me, I was four
years old when
I started playing and
programming on an Atari 800,
and it has changed my life.
I've been lucky
enough to help build
the Nintendo GameCube, the Xbox
360, and the Playstation 4.
And it has just
been a huge pleasure
to help bring better and better
games to more and more people
around the planet.
Now, I'm here at Google,
where, collectively, we
address the largest population
of gamers on the planet.
What we know as game developers
and platform developers
is that games need reach.
The more people you
can reach, the better
your chances for success.
That means being able to
get your games running
wherever players are--
on their phones, tablets,
laptops, TVs, everywhere.
We want to help bring your
games to everyone on the planet,
and we want to help
you, the developers,
to be as successful as possible.
We'll share how Google
Cloud can help your game
scale with their
amazing infrastructure
and bring new capabilities
like ML to all platforms.
Then you'll also hear how
Stadia plans to change the way
players access games and
how you, the developers,
can reach all those players.
But first, I'm going to start
with how Android and Google
Play can help you reach more
devices and more people.
Android is the most popular
operating system on the planet
and powers the largest
game platform ever built.
We reach over 2.5 billion active
devices, about half of which
are playing games.
This number continues
to grow as we
expand the ecosystem
to new markets
and bring new players
into the fold.
A lot of recent growth has
come from emerging markets,
such as India,
Brazil, and Indonesia.
And they're not just playing
your games, they're monetizing.
New paying users
in emerging markets
have tripled year over
year on Google Play.
Now these users may
be hard to reach.
They may be using unique
payment options or devices
that you haven't seen before.
And of course, all
those devices are
running an OS that wasn't
actually built for games.
We want to help make it easier.
We're committed to helping
you achieve your vision
by making it simpler to
build, optimize, and monetize
your games.
Let's start with some recent
work in tools and performance,
an area we continue to
continue to invest heavily in.
It's also near and
dear to my heart.
I'm an old school console
and game optimization guy.
I want access to
every byte and cycle
that the hardware can offer.
So we're making improvements
to memory management
and multicore performance.
In Android Q, our new memory
compaction improvements
mean your game can stay resident
longer and have more memory
to work with.
We're also working with OEMs to
mitigate multicore scheduling
issues so their devices
can be more predictable.
We know we have a lot more to
do here, especially in profiling
tools, and we're working on it.
Now touchscreen
games in particular
can really expose input latency.
Every frame and millisecond
counts for the best experience.
We've been working
closely with developers
like Kabam and NetEase to
understand the underlying
issues with the Android
display pipeline,
and we have something
new to show you today.
We're launching the
Android Frame Pacing API.
This synchronizes your game
code and the device's display
pipeline, resulting in
lower input latencies
and much smoother frame rates.
This is integrated into Unity,
and you can check it out
in The Garage.
And also, please check
out Fran's hilarious talk
on Android optimisation later.
He'll go into much more detail.
We're working on many,
new, exciting features
to help you measure and tune
performance, so stay tuned.
Let's now talk about
how we can help
you get your game discovered.
Now the Google Play Console
provides many tools,
helping you target, optimize,
and monitor your game
across the Android fleet.
And while it does enough
to fill 10, 20 talks,
I'm just going to focus on
a few, recent updates most
relevant to all of you.
Pre-registration--
it's a best practice
for building pre-launch demand,
to reach players earlier
in their lifecycle.
We launched to general
availability at GDC,
and many developers have been
using this to great success.
Today, I'm pleased to
announce that we're
expanding this feature
with the launch
of pre-registration rewards.
Now you can give users
special in-app items
as a reward for
pre-registering, and this
can have a powerful effect.
Nexon recently used this feature
for their new game, "FAITH,"
and players who received the
reward had over 20% higher
retention at day 30.
Now to help optimize
your acquisition funnel,
custom store
listings has let you
tailor your page based on
the country a visitor is
coming from.
We're expanding
this functionality
so now you can customize based
on pre-registration state
and install state.
So here in the
middle is an example
where a lapsed user
might be enticed back
by a new game mode, and
this can drive reinstalls.
We plan to launch this
in the near future
and encourage you to sign
up for the EAP today.
Now we've also extended
store listing experiments
to work with custom
store listings
so you can test and
optimize all these variants.
This was the number one
feature request from our EAP,
and we're very happy
to deliver it to you.
Another way that we
help drive acquisition
is by reducing install friction.
For example, with
Google Play Instant,
players can jump into a
demo of your game in seconds
without installing.
And we've seen that developers
who build great Instant
experiences can improve
their install conversion
by up to 20%.
Streamlining game
delivery is another way
we help reduce install friction.
So we've already re-architected
how apps get delivered
with the Android App Bundle.
This has let us tailor
delivery to a user's device,
sending only the necessary bits.
And this results in
considerable size savings.
Apps that switched to the Bundle
see an 11% install uplift.
Now this is one way
we actually help
you reach those users
in emerging markets.
They often don't have as much
mobile data or storage as those
of us in the developed markets.
I'm happy to say that we're
extending the App Bundle now
to include game assets.
You publish a single
artifact containing
your binary and its
assets, and Play
will keep those
assets up-to-date just
like we do with your binary.
If you sign up
for the EAP today,
you'll soon be
able to include up
to a gigabyte of game
assets in your App Bundle.
And we're not done.
We're working hard on
additional delivery options,
allowing greater flexibility,
larger game bundles,
and the same optimized
device targeting
that we provide elsewhere.
Now reaching all
those users does
nothing if your game
isn't up to snuff.
Last year at I/O, we
launched category benchmarks
so you could compare your
metrics with your category.
We heard your feedback that
the categories were too broad,
and it was hard to draw
meaningful comparisons.
So today, we're introducing
developer-selected peer
benchmarks.
Now you can compare
your game against a set
of 8 to 12 peers of your choice
and look for potential areas
for improvement.
Play Console is the
only place where
you can find this level
of benchmarking accuracy.
And we built a brand new
benchmarking platform
to work with all the important
metrics across the console.
Now the tools I've mentioned
help you build, promote,
and distribute your games.
Let me share some updates
to our billing platform.
Since last I/O, we've
added seller support
in over 30 new countries.
We've also added 20 new
carrier-billing partnerships,
expanding our DCB reach to
over a billion active devices.
Again, this is
critical in helping
those new users in
emerging markets
transact on the platform.
We're also constantly
running campaigns
to optimize the purchase flow,
reduce latency, drive growth,
and reduce cart abandonment.
We're seeing a lot
of you see success
with in-game subscriptions.
Now I used to help run
a subs business at Hulu,
and I learned just how hard
it is to do this really well.
So at Google, we've been
building all the tricks
of the trade into the platform.
And tomorrow, we'll be talking
about several new features
to help you manage
your subs business.
If you'd like to learn more,
please attend our talks
or check out the
demos in The Garage.
So you've built a
high performance game.
You've minimized its size.
Now it's all about
getting discovered.
Let me share some of the changes
we've made recently on Play
to help you reach more people.
Now with all the
creativity and innovation
that goes into a
game, we know it's
impossible to convey all of
that in a single app icon.
We need to show the
actual gameplay.
And today on the
Play Store, you may
have to go through
many layers to see
what a game is actually about.
So we're doing more to
bring the soul of your game
to the players right
on the Home page.
We're sharing more of your
screenshots, trailers,
and videos through several
new units, and it is working.
In some cases, we see
click-through rates
more than double.
Now another important discovery
signal is your game's rating.
For years, you have told us
that you want a rating based
on what your game is today,
not what it was years ago.
And we agree.
We know how hard
and how much energy
you put into improving
your games year over year.
So I'm happy to share
that we're updating
the way that average
rating is calculated.
Instead of a lifetime
cumulative value,
your new score will place
more weight on recent ratings.
Now users will not see this
new rating until August,
but you can all preview your
new rating in the Play Console
today.
We're also experimenting
with showing live ops events.
This is a new way to
reach more players
and drive engagements with
tournaments and sales,
or after a major update.
If you're interested,
please sign up for the EAP.
Now I've only mentioned
a few of the many things
we're doing to help you.
To learn even
more, please attend
the "What's New in Google
Play" tomorrow at 11:30.
We hope you take
advantage of these tools
and continue to share feedback
so we can continuously
improve them.
Now I've talked about
discovery and engagement
on the Play Store, but
off-store is just as important.
In 2018, over 50 billion hours
of gaming-related content
was watched on YouTube by an
audience of over 200 million.
Let me share some of the
interesting insights we found.
So 90% of gamers turn
to YouTube every week
to watch some gaming videos.
I'm one of them.
Thank you.
And developers spend more
than a quarter billion
on influencer content.
By connecting what we
know about people viewing
videos on YouTube with their
actual install behavior
on the Play Store,
we can actually
show the ROI for
these campaigns,
and it's pretty amazing.
For every one person who watches
a video, clicks the link,
and installs a game,
there are four more
that do the same without
clicking any links.
They're not trackable.
This 4x is an average
and depends on the game
and the nature of the video.
But we've seen multipliers
as high as 10x.
So this is extremely
valuable, and you
can expect us to build
more connective tissue
between YouTube and
all our game efforts.
So just giving you a small
taste of how Play is helping
you reach more players
than ever before.
Next, Sunil will tell
you how Google Cloud
is enabling new capabilities
for game developers
and helping them scale.
Please welcome Sunil.
[APPLAUSE]
SUNIL RAYAN: Thank you, Tian.
My name is Sunil Rayan, and I
lead Google Cloud for games.
Tian talked a lot about
reach, and games have never
reached more players
than they have today.
In fact, I think we have about
2.4 billion players out there.
And games have also
become so popular
that it's one of the world's
foremost form of entertainment
these days.
But with that level of reach
comes complexity, right?
So you're managing a game
across different geographies,
different languages, time zones.
And to reach a
player is becoming
more and more challenging.
Today's games are also played
across multiple platforms,
and cross-platform play is going
to start to become very vital.
Thirdly, the speed and
scale of your games
is just growing
faster and faster.
What used to take
probably months or years
to get to 10 million
users, it just
happens in a matter
of days right now.
And lastly, your game is
just not a game anymore.
It's an ecosystem of players,
content developers, viewers,
audiences, et cetera, that
are engaging with your game.
So you need to think about
all these different users.
What does that mean, though,
for you as a developer?
It means you need to
partner with somebody
who can simplify the
complexity of managing all
this infrastructure so you can
focus on what you love most,
which is build great games.
And what does that mean?
We think it means a few things.
One, your players who
play the game deserve
to enjoy the games in the
best possible conditions.
So your infrastructure needs
to be global, scalable,
and reliable.
And it needs to keep
up with the demand,
run quickly, and run globally.
But managing this infrastructure
can also take a lot of effort.
It shouldn't just be scalable.
It should be really easy
to manage and portable.
That's why we abstract a
lot of the messy things
about managing this
infrastructure so you can
focus on building your game.
Now on top of this
infrastructure, number two,
is we also are building
platform-agnostic services
so you don't have to rewrite all
the different back-end services
depending on which platform your
game is actually running on.
And third, because games
produce so much data--
if you think about storing
events every day from games--
you need to find a
way to understand more
about your players and
your game performance.
And you need to
have a team that can
sift through all this
massive amount of data
and analyze it at scale.
And we want to make
it easier for you
to extract these insights
from these games.
So let's go deeper into
each one of these points.
The basis of everything what
Google Cloud does or is doing
is its global
infrastructure and network.
We have invested
massive amounts of money
across the globe
in building regions
to support these data centers.
We've got 20 cloud
regions across the world,
and we have three more on the
way in Jakarta, Seoul, and Salt
Lake City.
And these regions are connected
with thousands and thousands
of miles of privately
owned fiber optic cables.
In fact, we also have 13
undersea cable investments
across the world.
But what does this mean in terms
for you as game developers?
You want your game
servers to be running
as close to your
players as possible,
and this is what should be
the backbone if you're truly
building a global game.
And hosting these games
on global infrastructure
will help ensure that your
players have a really smooth
experience, see
no latency issues,
and your services are
always close to the players.
Some of the world's
largest games
are actually running
on this infrastructure.
"Apex Legends," which I'm
sure many of you have played,
had a great launch by running
their game servers on Google
Cloud's Compute Engine with
the help of our friends
at Multiplay.
Multiplay is a managed
partner of Google Cloud
that provides a full
suite of services--
orchestration
services and scaling
tech-- to help host
your game servers.
"Apex" accumulated
a million players
in about eight hours and
almost 10 million players
in about three days.
So when talking
about reach, this
is the type of
global scalability
that Google Cloud
can offer your game.
Seamless performance
wherever your players may be.
It's not only "Apex."
We also announced
at GDC Google Cloud
was picked as the
cloud provider to host
game servers for the
highly anticipated sequel,
"The Division 2."
Massive, which is a Ubisoft
studio, and Google Cloud
worked together to use
the Cloud Compute Engine
and deliver a smooth online
experience for these players.
In fact, we had our
Google Cloud engineers
sit with the Massive engineers
in the same room to make sure
that they had a
successful launch.
We realize also that many
of your successful games
are already running on
other infrastructure.
But the need for
global games really
needs a different approach.
We're firm believers
in giving developers
flexibility to run their back
end and infrastructure where
it makes most sense for you.
That's why open source is
a key part of our strategy,
not just in gaming, but
also in Google Cloud.
We think we know a little
bit more about open source
because we invented Kubernetes.
For those of you who are
unfamiliar with Kubernetes,
Kubernetes an open-source
system for deploying and running
software at scale.
Because Kubernetes
is open source,
it gives you the freedom
to take advantage
of running your
software, whether it's
an on-premise, whether it's
in a hybrid environment,
or a public cloud infrastructure
with the GCP or something else.
This helps you so you don't get
locked into one cloud provider,
and you can move
workloads as you wish.
When you run Kubernetes though,
the best way to take advantage
is to basically have the people
who actually built it run it
for you as well.
So we're taking this
open-source approach,
and we're using it to build
game-specific services
and solutions.
And we're not doing it alone.
We're doing it with industry
leaders like Ubisoft and Unity
to bring you these
games services to life.
Agones, which is a open-source
dedicated game server hosting
solution, was built
on top of Kubernetes
with the flexibility
to tailor to the needs
of your multiplayer game.
You get native capabilities
to create, run, and scale
these dedicated game
servers on Kubernetes
using standard Kubernetes
toolings and APIs.
Building Agones on
top of Kubernetes
lets you also choose where
you want this to run,
whether it's
on-prem, whether it's
on our cloud or other clouds.
We also co-founded a
matchmaking framework
called Open Match with Unity.
And we call it
"framework" because we
want to take away the repetitive
elements off a matchmaker
so you can focus on
the main things, which
is the match logic.
And we give you the
flexibility for you
to put your match logic in.
So if you stop by
our Garage demo area,
we have experts that can
talk you through both Agones
as well as Open Match.
We embrace open source
because we want everybody
to use these solutions.
You don't just have to be a
large company with hundreds
of employees to use
these solutions.
Supersolid, a relatively
small company,
is using Agones in
their newest game,
"Snake Rivals," as an example.
We also want to make it easy
for you to deploy these services
into your games,
so we actually have
it available now in our
Google Cloud Marketplace
where you can launch Agones
with just a few clicks.
So I encourage you
to check it out.
Once you've had your
game up and running--
we talked about
infrastructure, we
talked about platform
services-- but now
that you have the
games up and running,
you have a new challenge.
I have all this
data, and how am I
going to manage and optimize
my game with this data
and think about
user acquisition?
Today's successful
games, as you know,
generate billions and
billions of events.
And as developers,
you need to find a way
to harness this data.
But simply managing and
analyzing this data, in fact,
is not enough.
With BigQuery, our globally
scalable, fully managed data
warehouse, you can have access
to the data warehouse that
keeps up with the data
volume and velocity,
enabling your data analyst
to get results really fast.
Not only that, we also have ML
built into BigQuery that you
can have your data analyst
start to build machine learning
models without really
having a PhD in doing so.
So as I said,
Google Cloud's goal
is to enable everyone
to use AI and ML,
so we've built a
suite of products
depending on how
nascent or advanced
your capabilities are in ML.
So if you look on
the left-hand side,
you have prepackaged, powerful
AI solutions that you can just
embed within your game.
So think about a translation
API that you can just
have help translate your
game chats in real time.
On the middle layer, we also
have built new products.
For example, we launched a
product called Cloud AutoML.
Because it's a technology
that helps build custom ML
models for you, all you need
to do is prepare the data
and set the objective
in terms of what you're
trying to achieve, and
it builds the machine
learning models for you.
And lastly, for people who
have advanced capabilities
in-house--
you've got a lot
of data scientists,
and ML scientists and experts--
you can write your own
custom models with TensorFlow
and use the Cloud
Machine Learning Engine
as a platform,
which is optimized
to run machine learning models.
So solutions like
Cloud ML have really
made AI experts
even more productive
and help beginners
who are starting
with ML build powerfully AI
systems that they could only
dream of.
Not only are we
providing tools, we also
see the potential of AI and
ML across different phases
in the game lifecycle.
For example, whether it's game
development-- so you have NPCs,
QA testing--
in your user acquisition
and retention
processes, as well as improving
the in-game experience.
And large companies like King,
Square Enix, DeNA, Netmarble,
are using Google Cloud
to get real insights
and embed these AI
solutions into their game.
Let's walk through some of
these use cases and examples
so we bring this to life.
King, famous producer
of "Candy Crush,"
is using BigQuery to analyze
massive amounts of data.
They have something
like 70 billion events
that are produced every
day that they store,
and they sift
through all the data.
But one of the cool use cases
that we had seen coming out
of King is they have used
this data to simulate player
testing.
Models are deployed to simulate
hundreds of game rounds
in parallel, allowing developers
to figure out how hard or easy
are the different games
based on the different skill
levels of players.
If they had to do this with
real players and games,
this used to take
them months or weeks
in order to come
up with how they
should design the challenge
level by different segment
types.
And now they can do it
in a matter of hours.
So this is the
type of things that
help them save money
so they can focus more
on creating as opposed to
waiting for data to load
and have these tests all done.
So this is one example
where King is actually
using it for play testing.
Another use case
that we've seen is
DeNA, which, with AI,
was breathing new life
into a three-year-old game.
The game was
"Gyakuten Othellonia."
It's a PvP strategy game where
before starting a battle,
you have to construct a deck.
And each deck has to
have about 16 characters.
They have all these
different characters
so players have to think about
3,000 different combinations.
And as a result, you have
a steep learning curve,
and there's a lot of churn
happening in the game.
So what DeNA did
is use BigQuery,
our TensorFlow
with a custom model
and with Cloud Machine
Learning Engine,
to help build a
recommendation engine
and an AI training bot
to help onboard the users
so they could guide their
users to build the right decks
so they can start
to play the game.
And this is in an existing
three-year-old game.
So it reduced churn,
and now they've
had even more downloads--
about 23 million--
since they made these changes,
and it's continuing to grow.
So you can embed
new life, basically,
in an old game with AI as well.
The last example I'm
going to talk about
is Netmarble, which uses AI and
ML across a wide variety of use
cases.
They've actually built
an AI-dedicated team
to push the boundaries of how
AI and ML can be used in games.
One interesting
problem that they
solved is a lot of
new game developers
spend hours and
hours building games,
but the last thing you want
to see is revenue leakage.
So for example,
Netmarble used a model
to improve their cheat
detection services.
They used the same models across
both their MMORPG games as well
as their strategy games.
And as a result, it helped them
retain the high-spend players
because they had ways
to detect anomalies
in the game to protect cheats
from entering the game.
So these are some
of the examples.
We're still in early days
as to how AI and ML will
change the game industry.
But hopefully, you've
gotten a little bit
of a taste of what some
of the leading companies
are doing with AI and
ML on Google Cloud.
So Tian talked a lot
about mobile developers
and helping them reach a
broader audience than ever.
I just discussed
how you can manage
the complexity of
reaching an audience
with global, reliable,
scalable infrastructure,
and leverage new
capabilities like AI and ML
across all platforms.
Next, I would like to hand
it over to John Justice
from Stadia to
talk about how you
can reach players and
devices in new ways with PC
and console-side games.
Welcome, John.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN JUSTICE: Hi.
Hi, folks.
I'm John Justice.
I run the product
team for Stadia.
What an exciting
time to be in games.
Today, we're going to talk about
how Stadia will help you reach
more users on more devices.
In March at GDC, we
announced our vision
for the future of games with
the Stadia platform reveal.
The response from the
game development community
has been remarkable.
We've had thousands of
companies apply for access
to our developer program.
Thank you to everyone who's
applied on stadia.dev.
We're rolling out
access to developers
purposefully over
the coming months
with a focus on making a
great experience for you
no matter what the
size is of your studio.
So if you signed up, we
appreciate your patience.
But I want to step
back for a minute
and talk about the
foundations of Stadia,
why it exists as a platform.
For PC and console developers,
the games you're making,
they're getting more
complex, they're
getting richer, higher
fidelity, and frankly,
more expensive to
make than ever before.
Now more than ever, you
need to reach more players.
Until Stadia, that
reach has been
gated by the cost of
hardware, hardware
that needs to be upgraded
for hundreds or thousands
of dollars every few years.
That generational reset limits
your reach as developers.
So until now, you've
faced a dilemma--
build a game that takes
advantage of the latest tech,
delivering the best visuals, the
4K visuals, the massive worlds,
all of that, or maximize
reach by targeting
the lowest common
denominator in your hardware.
And if you wanted to reach
players on different devices,
you'd usually just have
to rewrite your game.
You had to write your
game multiple times.
Stadia removes those dilemmas.
As developers, you're
always building
on the latest hardware.
You only have to build your
game once to run across devices.
And your players never have to
buy an expensive console or PC,
and they never have to upgrade.
And with Stadia's
YouTube integration,
you can reach players
wherever they are
and bring them into the game.
Your games deserve to be
experienced by the widest
audience possible on as many
devices as possible and as
seamlessly as possible.
So how does Stadia
actually work?
And more importantly, how do you
make a game for the platform?
OK.
How does it work?
A player presses a button
on the Stadia controller
that fires the input via
Wi-Fi to the Stadia instance
in the Google data center.
We process that input, run the
game logic, render the frame--
up to 4K 60 HDR--
encode the frame, and transmit
it back to the player.
If you're building a game
using back-end servers,
say, multiplayer,
you can use whatever
cloud provider you like
for that back-end server.
But if you want the best
performance, security,
and value, you'll
want to use GCP.
For more on that, go talk to my
friend Sunil, who was just on.
That Stadia instance, the
hardware running your game
in the Google data
center, it runs
Linux with Vulkan graphics.
Now when you're developing for
Stadia, you'll use the tools
and workflow that
you're already used to.
The Stadia plugin
for Visual Studio
adds a Stadia target just
like any other platform.
For shaders, we worked with
Microsoft on the DirectX shader
compiler to enable HLSL
to Spear V compilation
to make the transition to
Vulkan as simple as possible.
We've integrated the open-source
tools you already use,
including the LLVM compiler,
RenderDoc for graphics
debugging, Valgrind for
debugging and profiling,
and GAPID, which we've
optimized with the Android team
to work well for Stadia.
We've also integrated a large
and continuously growing
list of middleware, like Havok,
CRYENGINE, and Audiokinetic.
And of course, that list
includes Unity and Unreal.
Regardless of what engine you're
using, once your game is built,
you upload the
Stadia game package
to your development instance,
which streams it to players.
For those development instances,
we give you a few choices.
If you want to run
your game in our cloud,
you can use instances
in our data center.
If you prefer
running it locally,
we have Stadia dev workstations.
And if you want a
quad-instance server
to be shared in your
studio for your dev team,
we have those too.
So whether it's your cloud,
our cloud, or at your desk,
we support your workflow.
As you get into testing
your games for Stadia,
you'll find more of the benefits
that come with Cloud gaming
development.
No more pushing builds
to hundreds of testers
and waiting for
them to download.
Instead, you'll upload
a build to the cloud
and just send out a link.
The test team clicks that
link, and they're in the game.
This means faster iteration,
tighter feedback loops
during this critical stage.
All of that's managed
through the Stadia partner
portal, which you can
actually check out today
live in The Garage here at I/O.
So now we've covered
at a high level
how do you, as a developer,
make a game for Stadia, using
a single code base, reaching
desktops, laptops, tablets,
phones, and TVs.
If you want to dive more
into the tech behind Stadia,
we have a deep dive session
coming up at 3:00 PM
at The Garage.
It's being given by
our playability team.
It speaks directly to
the software and hardware
that powers Stadia streaming.
I highly recommend
you all attend.
OK, so as you move
from development
to testing and
finalling your game,
you'll eventually want to
unleash your game on the world.
When you think about
launching that game,
Stadia's YouTube
integration are designed
to let you reach more
players in new ways.
So let's talk about how a
player finds the game today.
The number one place where
they do that is YouTube.
The number one
activity people do
before buying a
game in the world
is watch a video of
that game on YouTube.
Until Stadia, after
watching that video,
someone would have
to jump through hoops
to buy it and then
wait to play it.
With Stadia, they go from
YouTube to play within moments.
And taking that further,
if you build State Share
into your game, players can
not only jump into your game,
but they can jump into that
exact compelling moment
that they were watching.
State Share enables
you, as a developer,
to compile the metadata
of your game world--
things like a player's
armor, or inventory,
the puzzle they were on, the
opponent they were facing,
any of those--
all of those into
a clickable link.
That link can be sent
anywhere on the internet.
And someone with that link,
they'll jump into the game
at that exact same spot,
the very moment that got
them excited about your game.
After someone's in
your game, they'll
want to play with their
friends, no matter
what platform they're on.
With Stadia, we support
cross-platform play
and cross-platform progression.
We leave the choice
to you, but we
will do everything we
can to make it possible.
Today, we covered how you
can use Stadia to reach
more users on more devices.
With a single code base,
a powerful workflow that
meets you where you are,
powerful YouTube integration,
and open policies,
you can get your games
into the hands of
players everywhere.
Stadia will be launching later
this year in the US, Canada,
UK, and much of Europe.
If you're interested in
learning more about the platform
and applying to access for
our developer platform,
please go to stadia.dev
now and apply.
Thank you for coming to
the first of many games
tracks at I/O. No matter if
you're focused on mobile game
development, scaling
your infrastructure
to support a global
audience, or you're
building your next great,
high end game experience,
Google is dedicated
to supporting you
in reaching more users
with your devices.
Please be sure to stop by The
Garage at I/O to learn more.
At Google, we're here
to be your partner.
We won't always be perfect,
but our commitment to you
is to remain vigilant, remain
humble, and always listen
to your feedback.
After all, without
the support of you
and the rest of the game
developer ecosystem,
everything you've heard
today simply would not exist.
For Tian and Sunil, as
well as the rest of Google,
thank you so much
for your attention
today and have a great I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]